choose your words carefully so end of
the year I get a little bit more self
reflective I like talking about sort of
the channel in general and things like
that so I got to do a video on sort of
my favorite and also least favorite
kinds of comments to get now this is
sort of setting aside the obvious ones
on both ends of the spectrum I'm not
gonna talk about comments being left
that are just flat-out trolling or that
call me I'm not gonna repeat the things
that some people call me or ones that
are just like I love you and everything
you do
I do appreciate receiving those but
that's like again that's part of the
obvious of course I like that and I
wanted to deal a little bit with some of
the less obvious stuff that I just I
really like seeing going on in the
comments cuz I as much as I have kind of
been complaining lately about some of
the stuff that have had to clear out and
some of the elements I've had to get rid
of on a semi-regular basis and that does
weigh on me I do love my comment section
at the end of the day I really do and
especially for a channel the size that I
have gotten to and will hopefully
continue to build from I think I've got
a pretty respectful comments section and
certainly one that I eye while I don't
enjoy some of the things I come across I
actually enjoy doing it but yeah so
there's gonna be good and bad on this
list now I'm actually gonna start with
the bad because I want to end positive
since it's gonna be a back and forth and
I've got three examples of each so
comments that drive me nuts you came
into this biased yeah no kidding so does
everybody like the whole the argument of
bias drives me nuts
now here's what I try and do cuz first
of all we all have biases positive or
negative that's another thing people say
bias like you can only be negatively by
Zagan something you can
positively biased towards something too
if you go in expecting it to be the best
thing you will ever see and are looking
for all the reasons for it to be good
that's a bias too but that's not even
why it drives me nuts why it drives me
nuts is because not only does everyone
have a bias I try really hard when I
recognize what my biases are when it
relevant to something that I'm talking
about I point them out if part of my
love for something is nostalgia I point
that out if something that really drove
me nuts about you know a film or an
episode of a TV show I can identify as
being probably specific to me and my
hang-ups I will point that out the only
time it's relevant to point out bias is
when somebody is claiming to not have it
or is hiding it I'm trying to be really
open with my biases so don't tell me I
came in bias yeah no kidding
anyways I don't more positive note the
sort of comments that I like getting is
something to the effect of I don't agree
with your conclusion but I get what
you're saying and those sort of comments
make me feel really good about sort of
the format that I do because obviously I
ramble
at the camera and I do not edit a lot
these days I you say that a lot more I
used to have you know shorter tighter
videos I don't really anymore and I I
mean part of that is it actually enables
me to do more regular updates but I do
think there's an actual positive outcome
to that which is that because a lot of
times I'm I'm rambling my thoughts out
you know to form them up and so that it
feels more like the conversation is you
you get are privy to my thought
processes on things so if I was if I was
more tightly editing like most of these
things I could cut by and probably about
half honestly if I really wanted them to
be to the point but the thing is what I
would cut would be all the little sort
of rambles and tangents and
clarifications and qualifications that I
put out while
getting to a point and then you would
only be left with my point and you
wouldn't know how it got there so if you
disagree with my point you just be going
well that's not right but because I
leave in all my rambling thought
processes you know it it allows you to
see how I got there it's like showing
your work you know fur in schoolwork
like for a math test the reason it's
important to show you work is even if
the answer you get isn't what the
teacher was looking for they can go over
and see how you got there and go oh not
what I was after but I do see how you
arrived at that I see where things went
here and that's kind of what I consider
so getting comments like that is a
little bit validating for the format I
do on this channel that I like it so
yeah yeah this this one bugs me a lot
you're always so negative haven't been
getting that one as much lately because
large you've been talking about Doctor
Who and because I don't call it the
worst thing ever the latest series I've
been told that I'm scraping to excuse it
and complement it but that's another
conversation I'm not even bringing that
up but yeah I have been accused more
than a few times I've always being
negative always looking for the bad and
things and there's two elements to that
one of which I can't control one of
which not my fault the one that I can
control is that's just how my brain
works like I I like to think that it
doesn't SAP the joy that I have out of
things but even if I can take the
enjoyment completely out of something I
can't stop my brain from kind of
cataloguing boy that was really good but
there was this little thing that could
have been a little better that could
have that could have function better
they could have you know flowed better
that moment was out of place you know
this little thing bugged me or if it
works the other way where like something
is Val go boy this didn't work I mean
there was that little thing but this
didn't work and I think this probably
comes up the most when I look at
trailers and teasers because when I look
at something for something that will
later exist I can't stop my brain from
bay
basically cataloging all the ways what I
just saw could possibly screw up and
that's just what my head does you know
and I try to counteract it if I can but
that's just kind of my thought process
now there is a half of this that is not
my fault that's you guys you guys watch
the negative stuff a lot more and that's
not even speculation
I have numbers if you want to take you
know basically any list that I've done a
best and a worst on the worst version
always has about double the views I mean
I've done it with more than just this
but you died quick easy comparison I did
the 10 best and ten worst Doctor Who
episodes written I did it for Russell T
Davies and I did it for Steven Moffat
and in both cases the worst list has
twice the views I am NOT responsible for
the fact that that's what you guys watch
more of sheesh all right coming back to
positive this is kind of connected to
the last one a lot though these kind of
intermingle and overlap but when
somebody says to me the unequivocal
that's you know I wouldn't have thought
to have looked at it that way and I
appreciate hearing that because I also
appreciate getting that I really enjoy
in the comment section when somebody
disagrees with me and gives their
reasoning and the angle at which they
came out something from that led them to
a different different conclusion so that
I can you know I can go oh well you
obviously have a perspective I didn't
have and now you've sort of let me in on
that a little bit and sort of hearing
that at least on some occasions I'm able
to do that for other people I think that
helps because I think you know the being
able to hear and get at least a glimpse
into the way other human beings view
things is healthy I think it's a good
thing to go oh all right
well that there's obviously a whole
thing with the way you came at this I
never would have thought of it like that
that is an interesting alternative and I
enjoy seeing it and I enjoy hearing that
about my own thing and it's it's funny
of if I was of a poor more paranoid bent
when I get comments like that I'd be
thinking oh god how weird is my brain
that people that like to me this is the
obvious normal thought process and other
people who I never would have thought of
it like that huh but I know it makes me
feel kind of nice so the last one on the
comments I really can't stand getting
and and before I say what this one is
I want to word I want to pick my words
very carefully and sort of my response
to this I just I want to be so careful
about how I how I say this and I would
come across so dude it's just a movie
calm down go to yourself why I hate that
so much because okay first off this
channel is got what even it's a geeky
pop-culture commentary kind of channel
this stuff is not the most important
stuff in the world but it's what the
channel is about so I don't think that
what's going on on Doctor Who or with
Star Wars or in Game of Thrones is the
most important thing going on in the
world but it's what I talk about here
heaven forbid I have strong feelings
about the things that I choose to talk
about here would you rather I was a
robot and had no investment and didn't
care about the things that this entire
channel is based on and more to the
point huh you know what for me
personally the two worst words that you
could say to me if I am mad or
frustrated are calm down you don't get
to tell me how to process stuff if I
need to rant it out
I will rant it out and then I will be
okay I will process
need to process you don't get to dictate
to me or to anyone else how to process
through what I'm going through or what
I'm thinking or what or what I'm feeling
based off something and you don't have
any business telling anybody what they
should or shouldn't care about or that
they do or don't care about something
too much people care about what they
care about some of it in the grand
scheme of the world
doesn't matter we still care that's fine
but let's go back to positive again so
my favorite thing to get and the in the
comments section and again this kind of
ties to the other stuff but it's when
people share their personal experiences
and that can come up when people explain
why a particular episode or movie really
connected with them and they sometimes
will share some of their history some of
their background to give me better
context for why it impacted them the way
that it did and I love that again sort
of related to you know to the things
that were said about you know oh I
didn't think of it that way or I didn't
agree but I saw how you got there you
know this is the purest way for me to
experience that like I like getting the
comments that basically say I kind of
did that for other people but I also
loved I loved getting that back I loved
seeing a comment that gives me a bit of
personal history of someone's you know a
story from someone's life a relationship
that they had with you know with someone
that really informed their feelings
about something and I really always
appreciate anyone who does that and it's
it's touching in a way that you would
feel comfortable even sharing some of
the song I mean some of the stuff that's
gotten shared with me any comments is
stuff I wouldn't expect people to share
and it's awesome and it's wonderful and
it gives me a nice warm fuzzy feeling
which is good because this time of year
Vermont is freezing why I got these
going besides they're cute
so thank you to the subscribers to the
viewers to the commenters all of you
except for the jerks but you know if I
haven't already blocked off the channel
try to get better
I do like engaging with people I
disagree with just don't be a jerk
the golden rule but most he aren't the
vast majority of my commenters I really
value the heck out of you guys so thanks
for everything
your thoughts comments you like to give
comments you like to see I would ask for
the most part that your responses on
this lien on the positive because I
think I got my own rants out but you
know I if you have something you need to
vent I won't stop you but I kind of
prefer this to be a little bit more on
the touchy-feely side comment section
wise but we'll see what we get whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it oh but
just hope you can do because there's
buttons and there's links including what
the right patreon if you want to support
me that way it does help but there's
other links to check out as well I got a
pol box there's all sorts of stuff down
in the description but if you don't want
to look at any of that that's fine too
cuz at the end of the day you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]